58 people died that night in a mass
shooting at the Route 91 Harvest Music
Festival right in front of Mandalay Bay
the death toll would eventually rise to
60. this year marks five years since the
tragedy and this morning we're hearing
from a woman who found her path to
Healing by leaving Las Vegas this is
Joanna hendricks's Survival Story
I remember saying like all I want is
peace in the Years following the Route
91 tragedy Anna Hendricks says she did
everything she could to regain a sense
of normalcy she went to therapy she went
to concerts she helped honor the lives
lost but Las Vegas which was home just
didn't feel the same I think there's an
underlying feeling that's always there
in the city and for her and her three
boys that meant it was time to move on
even to this day I love Vegas but
um Tennessee's healthy for us
Tennessee's a is a place that I have
been able to heal it gets healthy for
them to see me healing when it comes to
dealing with trauma there really is no
right or wrong it's what works for you
Jackie Harris is a behavioral health
consultant for the Vegas strong
resiliency Center she's been counseling
survivors since that tragic night on
October 1st with trauma it's not
something we quote get over you learn to
live a full and healthy and happy life
Diana says that life for her family is
in Tennessee it's different out here
it's very different it's healthier my
oldest said I would never leave here
because it's safe his birthday actually
falls on October 1st and Joanna says
this year they can finally celebrate
without the tragedy casting a shadow
this is the first year in five years but
it kind of just gets to be all about him
she says they'll continue their 58
random acts of kindness to honor the
lives lost but this year offers A New
Beginning yes this happened to us yes it
was a moment of our life but it doesn't
have to stop you
we also want to remind everyone that the
Vegas strong resiliency center is open
this week as it is every week to help
anyone who may need to talk you can find
several resources on their website as
well Vegas strongrc.org